ten nine eight
seven six five four
[Music]
three
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
you can be intentional live from the
headquarters of ramsey solutions
broadcasting from the dollar cart rental
studios it's the ramsey show where debt
is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host my co-host today a new
addition to the ramsey show long
time ramsay personality joe george
campbell has
joined the lineup for the ramsey show
and uh
he's going to be on with me all day
today answering your questions that's
not new to him but doing it in this
format is
long time listener first time co-host
dave i can't say that often
last time you get to do it yes you
better take that moment while you can
so uh as by way of introduction george
you've been with the team here
about eight years and you did not start
anywhere near the spotlight
no no i didn't know i wanted the
spotlight i kind of fell into it
accidentally because i started as
an intern i don't even think it was
legal at the time but we found myself a
temp position here and said hey this guy
seems like a good guy
let's get him in for a few months and
we'll say our goodbyes and luckily it
didn't end
after the few months i found a full-time
role in the marketing team
yep so i started doing that and um in in
the marketing team there are sometimes
folks that have uh
personalities absolutely a lot of them
uh
they they've got the chops but they
should stick to marketing and so i was
in email marketing for
a number of years and moved into social
media for the personalities and so i've
always been drawn to
the personalities and their message and
finding creative ways to reach people
out there
little did i know that eight years later
i would be the one
reaching people with a message with my
own face my own voice which is
it's just astounding to me that god has
done this this is wild
so you went from that and did we use you
as
a uh have you do host a few things first
or was the video channel first
it all started with a little thing
called battle of the bands and we've
talked about it you've probably heard
about on the show it's legendary here
ramsey solutions
it's one of our selling points to work
here is it's one of the biggest events
we do
and it's all team members forming bands
and so as you know i was in bands for
the first three years and i got sick of
losing
i'm a good musician i'm not a great
musician and so i saw
an opportunity to go hey what if instead
of playing in a band i hosted the event
instead because at that point any warm
body could get up there on stage
and host yeah and so i asked for the
opportunity to kind of host that year
and uh it all went from there into this
hosting role yeah and then you've hosted
all of our events for years our live
events and the video channel for many
years yeah
shout out to uh the youtube crazies as
they're affectionately called i know
they're they're all watching with pride
right now
uh having a good time but it really
started one of their own has made it
i am one of you guys this is proof that
you can do anything you set your mind to
uh so hosting all the ramsey events for
four years hosting the ramsay show video
channel
and hosting all kinds of things yeah for
four years now became one of our master
financial coaches behind the scenes as a
part of that and then we put you into
much more uh upfront things in the last
two or three years as you moved into
ramsey personality role
yeah yeah the borrowed future was a big
one borrowed future podcasts millions
and millions and millions of downloads
about the student loan debacle
the epic failure of that and you're the
host of that all the way through of
course
um you know the video channel live
events uh
big in the high school curriculum oh
yeah foundations and personal finance
our high school stuff your people seen
you in that for years
and so and uh you're getting ready to be
a baby step seven personally so that's
like the ultimate qualifier oh i'm so
pumped
to get the house paid off i was just an
average millennial like when i started
here as an intern
i had average amounts of debt i had
thirty six thousand dollars in student
loan debt i had four thousand dollars in
credit card debt
and i started working here and i went
you know if this guy is really what he
says he is then these baby steps
should work and so i went what if i just
went all in not ish
what if i went all in on the baby steps
and do everything we teach the ramsey
way
where would it take me in life and here
i am eight years later and uh soon to be
paying off my house
well i mean but really the the net
result of the whole thing was that
whitney worked here you met whitney oh
you married way up we got to talk about
that
now the res now now the the baby steps
start working
the key to winning with the baby steps
is marrying someone at ramsey solutions
so i met my lovely wife whitney here at
ramsey solutions
and which you know it's touchy it's
touchy we don't disallow dating
but you can't be married and work here
unless you do the loophole that i did
which is meet here and get married here
oh there it is did you know that did i
just oh no i think i just
unveiled the loophole i didn't know that
that's okay it's okay they didn't know
that until you revealed it but that's
okay
so i met her and we were we were both
already out of debt at that point
and she's of course all in on the baby
steps and so we got married and we went
what if we really go all in together and
attack this thing
and so we've been gazelle intense now
we've been married coming up on three
years
and honestly she's more aggressive than
i am dave i try to slow her down and she
just won't stop she just wants to
get this house paid off to have options
to have a meeting your own schedule paid
off the next 12 months
oh yeah probably by april 22 is what
we're aiming for
okay wow and you're how old 32 years old
have i paid for house baby step seven
that's about as ramsey home grown as it
gets
top to bottom wife baby steps intern to
personality
i mean the whole thing's homegrown i
drink the kool-aid now i sell the
kool-aid it's amazing
if we had a test tube baby you'd be in
it
if we designed the dna of a ramsey thing
hey it's 2021 be it
is possible anything's possible we could
clone you george next that's what's
coming next
that's not what the world needs george
campbell with a k you can follow him
on twitter you can follow him at
official george camel on his facebook
you will see him frequently speaking for
us on the subjects of money
and of goal setting and life all the
things that we ramsey personalities all
do
uh he was on good morning atlanta this
morning yeah doing a media appearance so
you will see him everywhere he's been
doing
all those things and we have added him
to the lineup as a co-host periodically
here
on the ramsay show so we'll be taking
your calls today at triple eight eight
two five
five two two five and
the last few moments before the
commercial break we need to tell people
there's a brand new podcast comes out
today that you're the host of yes it
came out yesterday actually
and uh the first two episodes of ten are
out
of drum roll please the fine print
all about the hidden truths that are
keeping people broke and you've been
talking about this stuff for years dave
this is nothing new but what's new is
the format
it's narrative it's storytelling we talk
to outside experts we hear stories of
people who got screwed
and we make it fun and it's short form
so it's not a big commitment for the
average podcast listener out there
and the goal is to reach the people that
we're not currently reaching who go you
know i don't know i love my rewards
i don't know i'm all in on this crypto
stuff and i want to help people
understand the trends
so they can avoid falling for the traps
that's what it's all about
so the true cost of credit card rewards
is out how turbotax is screwing you is
out
uh now is the worst time to buy a house
is out how to bulletproof your money
no that's not out but it will be soon
however we'll approve your money for the
next pandemic
uh could bitcoin be your ticket to
wealth those are coming up
uh after pay affirm klarna should you
buy now or pay later
the dirty truth behind your credit score
and how the robin hood app
steals from the rich and the poor
everyone everyone i didn't know you took
aim at robin hood
we're not fooling around here dave
there's a lot of sketchy companies
there's a lot of slick products and
marketing out there
that are trying to reel people in and
take from their wallet and i want to
help them
avoid that i want to help them advocate
for themselves financially and stand up
against this toxic money culture
that we exist to rally against new
podcast is called
the fine print hosted by our
own ramsey personality george campbell
right here from the ramsey network you
can check it out anywhere fine podcasts
are found
and there's a whole bunch of places you
can get it of course you know about
apple and google and
spotify but anywhere you listen to
podcast you'll find that sucker
check it out the fine print because you
ought to know that you got to read the
fine print your mama told you that right
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to pure talk
they use the same network as the larger
providers for much less
for just 30 a month get unlimited talk
text
and six gigs of data with no contract
the average family saves over 70 dollars
a month
by switching to pure top just go to
puretalk.com
and enter the promo code ramsey to save
50
off your first month pure talk simply
smarter wireless
[Music]
welcome to the ramsey show where we talk
about your life and your money my
co-host today ramsey personality george
camel
is with me the phone number here is
triple eight eight two five five
two two five eric is in charlotte north
carolina hey eric welcome to the ramsey
show
hi thanks for taking my call sure man
what's up
um so i'll just get right down to the
question um the question is instead of
selling our home and taking the equity
and buying an upgrading at home
is there any reason we shouldn't do a
cash out refinance and remodel our
current home to basically be the home we
would have purchased otherwise
uh well i don't teach people to do to
borrow money uh or to borrow more money
if you do sell and you go buy a
different mortgage i guess that
has the same exact effect to your point
um
exactly but uh the problem on a refi on
a remodel
is people have a tendency to overbuild
the neighborhood
yes so what's your home worth
today um today probably 100
what would it be worth after the remodel
maybe 120. and what would the remodel
cost
i'm estimating on the high end here
we're probably 40.
okay so you're gonna lose half of the
money
oh yeah i understand that right you're
going to spend 40 and you're going to
increase your value 20.
that that would increase i mean that
would include
repairing a three-car port garage in the
back and turning one of those carports
into a
small apartment which still makes your
property worth 120
probably yeah so you still lost 20 grand
yeah that makes sense missing something
no i think the math on this doesn't add
up it doesn't sound like it's worth
renovating here if he wants to upgrade
and sell the house that's fine but it
doesn't seem like it's worth doing this
cash out refi and doing all these
renovations to only get that much
extra yeah if you could increase the
value at least exactly what
your cost was then we'd have an argument
to have and the next question would be
uh if you have a hundred and forty
thousand dollar home
what is the average are you in a
neighborhood or in a rural setting
it's a very small town in north carolina
okay when people are looking for
150 000 houses do they drive down your
street or do they drive down your street
looking for hundred thousand dollar
houses
um hundred thousand dollars yeah
probably a hundred yeah so my other
point is you're about to overbuild the
neighborhood
so i think your actual analysis at the
beginning was
very good and very correct eric in that
um i i think you're right i think you're
only going to increase it to 120
and it's still going to make you one of
the most expensive houses on your street
and that's the very end of the piece of
real estate you don't want to be you
want to be one of the least expensive
homes
in your area because you're going to get
the most increase in value and have the
highest probability of selling it
when you get ready to turn it over and
so george overbuilding the neighborhood
is
the swimming pool edition uh these year
these days it's the water park in the
backyard
when when i was growing up um on the
other side of the tracks the swimming
pool was
actually a swimming pool today when
people don't talk about a swimming pool
it costs more than a house well there's
landscaping there's a slide
and so he's not doing that that's not
what he's doing but that's the kind of
stuff that sets you up
for spending four times as much as
you're going to increase the value
and you talk about that in the financial
peace university lesson on real estate
making sure you're not overbuilding go
don't get the most expensive house in
the neighborhood
and if he does this that's what's going
to happen and no one's going to want to
buy the most expensive house
in the neighborhood yeah i actually just
sold my personal home
and i had violated that you over built
one of the reasons that uh was you know
it's a big stinking house but
uh one of the reasons i sold it was this
hot real estate market was a good time
to undo
that mistake and get out with my skin
intact yeah
but uh it was not the main driving
reason the main driving reason was
sharon says time to move
and we operate around our house on swi
sharon once it's my favorite rule
and so uh you've got whitney wants it
wwe
oh yeah we're feeling that yeah and
that's pretty much what you do if you're
smart man
yes it all comes down to patience
michael is with us michael's in tampa
florida what's up michael
hi david george thanks for taking my
call here's my question
i'm in the market for a small compact
truck i'm 38 years old my wife and i are
recently in baby step seven and about
six months ago became
an everyday millionaire way to go
thank you thank you it's been fun i've
been looking at a new truck that's going
to hit the market
this september october which will retail
for about twenty thousand dollars
is that that little colorado uh it's a
ford maverick
oh yeah i saw that okay cool yeah so
because of my personal thoughts on cars
i've kind of sworn off
buying a brand new car uh probably ever
however with the current
coveted situation and the supply and
demand related
to inflation i'm afraid that this
vehicle
in two years if i were to buy a two-year
used car
will cost about as much as it's
retailing for today so my question is
am i being impulsive considering a new
car should i go forward with that or do
i simply need to go
take a cold shower well you told me
you're an everyday millionaire correct
yes sir and this car is 20k yes sir
that sounds like a real small portion of
your world
and you've done really well for yourself
i mean we hear people who are in debt
who want to buy a 50k
truck and so you guys have put yourself
in a position to win and i don't see any
reason you can't pay
cash for this truck brand new
yeah i just i i it just eats me a little
bit
is this the emotional factor
appreciation hit and and i guess
i guess just kind of related to that is
what are our thoughts on the
on the inflation factor with the
the shortage of supply and demand over
the next 18 to 24 months
well the supply demand problem was
created by factories being shut down by
covid
okay and so there's a shortage of new
stuff coming off and when the shortage
of new stuff coming off
rolled its way down into the used market
it created a shortage in the used market
and both of them have shot way up in
cost uh so they you know the auto market
is among many of the markets that were
disrupted by people not going to work
and doing and building stuff at
factories and so the answer to your
question is as soon as they're all back
to work and the supplies
uh starts to even out the prices are
going to even out
and so i don't think you're going to
continue to see this level of inflation
and use vehicles because there's going
to be a supply of new vehicles
offsetting it
and just like there always was so they
just got to catch up it's already
catching up
it's not as bad as it was three months
ago same thing happened with lumber and
houses
it spiked way up and there's all these
jokes about lumber's more expensive than
gold and that was true for a little
while
but you know the lumber factories are
catching back up and that's going to
calm the new housing market down and
then that's going to calm the used
housing market down
it's not going to cause it to depress or
go the other direction
but it's just going to smooth it out and
this was just an unusual anomaly
following a shortage
of supply demand so i don't think that
enters into your equation dude
it's a 20 000 truck you got a million
dollars
you're not being impulsive you haven't
done anything impulsive in 10 years
he needs to have some fun buy the truck
this is why you do this man
uh you're a millionaire you're in a 40
20 000 truck if it burns to the ground
and you have no insurance on it
three days after you buy it your your
life doesn't change
the ratio of 20 000 to a million your
life doesn't change
georgia's exactly right it's a small
part of your world which is where
depreciating assets should be if you
want to continue to build wealth
and so that's why it's dumb to buy a 50
000 car when you're worth
having negative net worth and you make
50 000 a year
yeah it's not dumb it's beyond stupid
and crazy but people do it every day
on payments you're at the other end of
that spectrum
so if i were you if i woke up in your
shoes
i would buy the truck sweet little that
little truck's sweet too have you seen
oh yeah website on it
i'm tempted and i'm not even a truck guy
but that's a great price point
yeah and he's done well i've noticed
this uh this has been a theme the people
who are really responsible
have the hardest time making these
purchases because it's emotional for
them because of how
diligent they've been and how well
they've done financially they feel bad
and i want them to go hey you've
you're winning now is the time to do
those kinds of things have some fun
yeah that's exactly right there's what
happens though is he's been so diligent
as you said
and your brain gets locked in that
groove of
being frugal and that's what that's the
magic that got us here
and we don't want to abandon that and so
it's hard to loosen up and the only way
i've been able to loosen up is i do two
things
uh one is i increase my generosity which
seems to give me emotional
permission then to enjoy some of the
money personally
but on top of that then i just make sure
it's an amount of money if i set
firefoot to it
on my kitchen table and it just burned
up that i really wouldn't change my life
you'd be okay then you're okay it's a
small like you said it's a small part
of your world this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at eight eight two five five
two two five in the lobby of ramsey
solutions
on the debt free stage in person ryan
and christina are with us hey guys how
are you good good how are you
better than i deserve where you guys
live
rockford illinois cool welcome to
nashville
and all the way down here to do a
debt-free scream how much have you paid
off
around 188 000. how long did that take
three years in one month very good
and uh were your range of income during
that three years
around 180 and down to 120.
okay wow okay there's a story there yeah
what kind of debt was the 188
um mostly her student loans
and then uh i had a rental property
that uh i decided i wasn't making any
money on anymore so we just needed to
dump it off that works okay what do
y'all do for a living
uh i work as a security training
instructor for a nuclear plant in
illinois
and i'm a nurse okay cool so that was
from nursing school a lot of the debt
yeah i had my bachelor's before i went
to nursing school
so then a bunch from just my bachelor's
and then adding nursing school on top of
it
okay cool so tell us what happened three
years ago that put you guys on this
journey
um i had heard about you in my early
twenties
and i worked as a cna i just never had
enough to get ahead and
just a ton of excuses and then after i
had my daughter
we were paycheck to paycheck and it just
wasn't working
you know i wanted to stay home longer i
had to go back to work at six weeks with
her
and um just not being able to stay home
like i wanted to with her
it just kind of disgusted me so
um decided to actually put the plan into
work
okay cool and so how long you guys have
been married
uh in november it'll be
eight eight years okay all right so
uh obviously ryan uh christina comes to
you and goes uh this didn't work and i'm
done with this we're about to change
some stuff what did you say
um if you want to give it a go let's
let's do it i'm
i mean i'm pretty easy going uh i wasn't
really
100 on board with it because given how i
spent my money all the time it was
not the greatest but uh
it's really worked for us we i got on
board pretty quick when i started seeing
some of those smaller
student loans drop off
and just went full tilt what got you
guys on the same page it sounds like you
were kind of floating along like well
all right maybe and she's kind of like
well what was that moment where you guys
said we're doing this thing
we're all in once i started seeing all
the loans drop off it really
kind of sold me like all right yeah
we're definitely making progress on this
and we just need to stick to it to get
all this done
yeah so we just focused and
went forward with with continuing
knocking off the loans as
as they went through and uh here we are
with no debt wow well mortgage
well the more yeah but 188 thousand
dollars gone in three years is stinking
impressive
i mean you kind of make this sound like
well we just kind of wandered along and
then it went away it's almost 200
freaking thousand dollars
it probably could have been done a lot
quicker but we also
she's going to school full time as well
for
a nurse practitioner oh that's where the
income drop is we
cash flowed that uh and then ivf
ivf for our our youngest was all cash
flowed
income drop was once she had him and
covid hit
and with everything the uncertainty of
what was going on
uh we were in a place to where
with just my income we were able to keep
her home so she could spend more time
with him and
not rush back out to work which was the
start of this story
yes so um it just kind of went all
full circle and now she's back to work
again and
we're just working on knocking the
mortgage down
and then we're going to move out of
illinois and hopefully down your way
hopefully down here well way to go you
guys i'm so proud of you
thank you very very cool now that you've
not paid off 188 thousand dollars after
eight years of marriage you learned to
work together
you saw that progress the progress sold
you yes
there's nothing like winning to get you
on board right right and uh uh
this is what this works this stuff works
and so now i'm on
now that you've been through all of that
and you're standing here with
no debt except the mortgage how does
that feel
good pretty amazing yeah huge weight off
the shoulders
yeah because you've been carrying that a
long time yeah i mean
eight years you've been carrying it
basically right well i've had student
loans for
ever yeah yeah and then some huh yeah
yeah
all right turns out they're not good
debt no
do not do not do it wow what exactly did
you guys do i mean it sounds like there
were some sacrifices that had to be made
here you couldn't live the way you were
living
what's the key to getting out of debt no
vacations
yeah um be frugal
yeah very frugal we just learned to
manage our money and watch where it was
going
using every dollar app leave leave the
once alone and just focus on the needs
what was one of those wants you said
this is hard to give up but i'm willing
to do it if this is what it takes i like
beach vacations
she loves she's really was missing out
on this machine thing
her theme here her vacations me
uh anything firearm related yeah oh
i had to put a lot of that on hold oh
you put off buying guns
man that's tough he treated all right i
can give up the beach but
now we're good yeah okay oh my gosh
well now you're free and now you can go
to the beach and buy a gun yep
or buy a gun and go to the beach
whichever one you wanted yeah it's all
good
that's living like no one else and so
later you can live and give like no one
else so very very very well done
good stuff you guys and you brought the
kiddos with you what are their names and
ages let's have them join you on the
stage uh logan
he's 14. um and then michaela
my daughter she is four and then we have
wyatt who is 10 months old
ah it looks like some cheerleaders in
the action there grandma and grandpa
bringing them in
yep that's an excuse to come forward
very cool good stuff
all right we got a copy of the legacy
journey for you because that's the next
chapter in your story for sure
you've changed your whole family tree
look at that great family ready to rock
and roll man i love it
and a copy of the total money makeover
for you to give away somewhere and
pay it forward for someone ryan
christina logan michaela and
wyatt from rockford illinois 188 000
paid off in three years one month 180 to
120 in income and now back up again
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
three two one we're debt-free
this is how it's done
wow powerful family tree changed just
like that
just like that just three years and one
month of some sacrifice
this is what i stumbled into i would
like to say
i had a great epiphany in my
intelligence brought it forward but i
stumbled into this fact because i'm a
math nerd
and it wasn't it wasn't readily apparent
to me but as i started working with
people
and it has been the difference in the
ramsey message top to bottom
personal finance is 80 behavior it's
20 head knowledge you've got to do
something to modify your behaviors
or all of your freaking theories in the
world don't work and when he saw
actual results by paying off the
smallest debt which he would have never
seen if they had paid off their highest
interest rate debt first the dead
avalanche
yeah that's a bunch of crap in it so the
uh you know
it paid off those smallest debts and you
know what i did it got him engaged got
them both engaged they started to
believe
and that hope kicks in and throws gas on
the fire
changes everything oh absolutely and and
as you heard from her voice
they wanted options and they realized
until they got out of debt
they don't have all the options in the
world they have to do what they have to
do
yeah that's exactly right she was that
that idea to go to a beach vacation or i
didn't be able to be home with the
babies and
and when you're carrying around on your
shoulders 188
000 it's a problem yeah well now they
got all the guns and all the ocean time
in the world
no payments baby that's what you can do
he sounds like a bad rock band
[Laughter]
i love it this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we take your calls
about your life and your money the phone
number is triple eight
eight two five five two two
five you jump in we'll talk about you
right in front of you
new podcast launched yesterday on the
ramsey network it's called the fine
print george campbell my co-host to my
right
is the host of it the first two of ten
episodes dropped yesterday
how turbotax is screwing you and the
true cost of credit card rewards
and george you are diving deep into the
fine print of these situations
absolutely i'm doing the research for
them to save them some time and money
here and you are featured in the turbo
tax episode
where we really unpacked the strategy uh
of turbo tax it's not
tax software anymore it's a front door
to boatloads of debt because they bought
credit karma
they've got all the intuit companies out
there and they're ready to sell you on
some loans down the line yeah that's the
goal that's the goal for sure
the data proves it oh yeah ryan is with
us in denver hey ryan
welcome to the ramsey show thank you
dave it's an
honor to talk to you and great to see
you on the show george thank you
how can we help today so here's my
situation so
i have a current job offer to make about
30
000 above what i currently make and the
ability to work 100
remote um the problem is i i like the
firm i'm currently at and uh i just got
a promotion with a nice
pay raise and bonus so i'm torn between
being loyal to my current employer and
the co-workers that i really like
or taking the pay bump in the
opportunity that
seems like the better deal for the
moment
well if you took work remote out of it
it might change my answer
and um because i i
am seeing several pieces of valid
research come out
that is very clearly saying man was not
meant to be alone
and the productivity and the quality of
work coming out of
remote working companies is going to be
and is uh less than
companies that actually worked where
people actually work together
being in the same room with someone has
a multitude of advantages from
communication
to quality of relationships to trust to
uh and all of that affects productivity
and affects quality of life on the job
so remote workers are
you know the research is coming out
they're just straight up lonely
but it sounds really appealing for
someone who's not necessarily an
extrovert
and it sounds really appealing for
certain job types for you to sit at home
and pack on a computer and get it done
uh but at the end of the day it's not
turning out the way everybody thought it
was going to so
i i think that's a temporary move if you
take it i don't think it's a career uh
you know a destination for you it's i'm
going to go take this because it's 30
grand but i'm pretty sure in 24 months
i'll be doing something else
yeah and ryan you said you you really
like your coworkers you're going to miss
that when you're on zoom calls all day
it's going to feel like you don't have
any
so what's your current income right now
what what kind of jump are we talking
like from 69 000 up to 90
yeah what do you do i'm an auditor for a
public accounting firm
okay um well it would be unbelievably
tacky
for you to walk in and go you guys just
gave me a raise and i won another one
it's not enough uh
so i i mean i'm i'm interested
how old are you i'm 24.
wow okay what would be your best theory
as to why you're worth a hundred
thousand to one company and seventy
thousand to another
i mean uh the job offers kind of for
a little more specific type work um
okay sorry so um i would say
the reason is for uh just just the
qualifications that you would have to
have for this for this new type
type of job whereas you know
what's that don't you have those
qualifications
yes okay so why are you only worth 70
for one company and you're worth 100 for
the other with the same exact
qualifications
um i just just the line of work i mean
it's kind of it's different different
type of work so with auditing there's a
lot of
there's a lot of opportunity a lot of
people coming into the market you know
and and it took takes a little while at
bigger firms to kind of work up
whereas you're very replaceable in audit
um
unlike uh this type of industry that i'd
be moving into
it's kind of more specific and does your
firm offer
does your firm offer that service that's
specific that this other firm offers
so they do but not not at the location
not in denver
okay where's this new job at if you is
it local or is it remote
oh it's all remote so you wouldn't have
to go anywhere yeah
yeah here's the thing i'm worried you
take this thing and you realize oh my
gosh i hate these people and it's toxic
and it's super stressful and i'm working
60 hours a week
and it's not what i thought it was and
it's not worth 50 grand let alone 30.
yeah i i you do what you want to do i
don't think there's a wrong answer
if you take it um i'm going to introduce
the idea that it's more temporary than
maybe you had thought
because i think you're going to run into
problems 24 36 months out
because i think we're going to start to
see this is my theory we do ramsay
doesn't have remote work
we don't have any okay because we really
have seen a major difference when we're
in the same building together as a
matter of fact we spend an
inordinate amount of money being in the
same building together building the dead
gum building
you know and so we believe in it that
much we believe in the net result to the
customer
uh the net result of the quality of work
the uh environment the retention of
talent the culture and so forth so all
of that to say
you're asking a guy who has a skewed
opinion on this
um and so my theory is if you take that
other deal it's going to be a temporary
deal and that's okay to do it 24.
if you want to make 30 grand more a year
that's not a bad thing and you got
a bunch of freedom from work remote
that's fine but i don't think you'll be
there when you're 30.
still doing that uh just based on
talking to you and i think these trends
are going to
blow up a lot of people are already
zoomed out i'll just tell you
and so uh but but now the other thing
you could do
if you don't take it is i would go back
into the current firm and say
i've got this offer on the table i'm not
going to take it
but i think it's fair to let you guys
know this is on the table and i am
staying here
because of the relationships and what i
and and because i value this firm and
uh you guys just gave me a raise i'm 24.
now
but what i do want you to know is that
you're going to have to show me a path
forward
and because the next time this comes up
i got to think about it again
and so just you don't have to do it
today but over the next coming months
you need to give me a path forward where
i can
earn more money for this firm so you can
pay me more money
i want to know how i can add value yeah
so that i can make more and you can do
that with humility and you've got the
work ethic and you've got the chops and
you ask for hey i just want a growth
plan i'm willing to work and do what it
takes to get to that salary
just let me know what it takes and let's
have that conversation and the way i do
this too
is is i reverse the shoes and say okay
put your employer's shoes on
i got a 24 year old guy walks into my
office and goes i just turned down the
30 000
race not
uh hey look what i got okay uh
cause i'm gonna tell you take it if you
come in waving that under my nose go for
it as an employer i'd
say you feeling hoppy jump it's your
last day you know that's good
you know your spirit leaves you i'll
take your body with it so let's do that
you know i'm gonna be mean about it but
i'm just
as so if you switch see seats though and
you say okay if you're the employer
and the young man walks in and says i
just turned this down
because i'm thankful for this place
being loyal
and also telling you what's going on and
really all i ask is in the next few
months that you show me how i can add
value
so that i'm worth thirty thousand
dollars more in various
in the very near future yeah uh not
asking you to match this
uh but but i am asking you show me a way
where i can be valuable
now an employer like me that guy that
gal
i love them that's perfect yeah because
that's somebody that's in it to win it
for the long term
with the team they're going to stick
around it's going to be worth investing
in them it's going to be worth giving
them maybe an immediate raise even
but you don't ask for it no not today do
with humility
that's it that's the whole thing george
campbell ramsey personality my co-host
today
here on the ramsey show and of course
james charles is our producer kelly
daniels our associate producer
and phone screener we'll be back before
you know it
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice ramsey
personality george campbell
is my co-host today here on the air as
we answer your questions about your life
and your money
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five five
two two five george is launching along
with the ramsey networks
and our whole podcast division a new
podcast today
or actually launched yesterday
technically called the fine print
that's right the hidden truths that are
keeping you broke i just love a good
podcast dave i hosted our bard future
podcast
i host the entree leadership podcast i
thought why not one more
there's room and so we did it it just
launched we've got a 10 episode
season that's coming out right now and
here's where it all came from
you've been taking calls like this from
people who fell for money traps and a
lot of people out there are not where
they want to be financially wouldn't you
know it
and they don't know who to trust they
don't know what to do the steps to take
they're listening to headlines they're
listening to social media they're broke
friends
to make all these major money decisions
and we believe that winning with money
doesn't have to be complicated
and so what i want to do is do the
research for them break down the myths
break down the traps
help them understand the trends so that
they can make smarter decisions with
their life and their money
ah there we go check it out george
campbell
and the team the new podcast is called
the fine
print anywhere great podcasts are sold
but
that would be on of course uh what
youtube no i'm not youtube we are on
youtube we are on youtube
it's yeah it's it's 20 21. you got to be
everywhere so we're on youtube spotify
google podcast apple podcasts
you name it we're everywhere if you just
search for the fine print and it's we're
trending closely to the ramsay show
i'm starting to get nervous for you dave
okay but if you if you knock it off
it'll be in the fine print
that's right i'll do an episode on you
you never know
yeah the first two episodes have already
dropped how ter how turbo tax is
screwing you
and the true cost of credit card rewards
be sure and check
them out david's with us in south bend
indiana hi david welcome to the ramsey
show
hey dave hey george good to talk to you
guys you too what's up
so me and my wife just got married on
july 24th
and congratulations thank you thank you
so we just got back from the honeymoon
um so with the wedding gifts we have
from all our guests we got about
a little over uh four grand to uh
you know that we have our choice to
choose from
the thing is uh so my wife she's pretty
much ready
pretty much on baby step three now now
my situation is i'm still on baby step
two
and i owe about 25 grand so
you know now that we have some cash that
we need to make a decision with
um i know that she feels we've had
discussions and i'm on speaker right now
so she can hear you too
um but we've had discussions that
you know whereas in this this is even we
got married but this is more my debt i
mean it was my stupid decision that
why still got 25 left to pay sorry
and you know i'm sorry you're wrong and
the
your wife already wins the first
argument
when you walk down the aisle and the
preacher said and now you are one
all that bs you just spouted went away
you don't have my debt and you're dead
anymore you don't have my
anything anymore we have our your
pronouns changed you're home from the
honeymoon
and so we have a pile of debt and we
have some money
and we have an income and we are going
to develop a plan that we
are going to work together or you're
going to struggle in your marriage and
in your wealth building both data from
30 years of working on this backs up
what i'm saying david
30 years millions of families we've
worked with
very few people build wealth when they
act like they're a joint venture instead
of a marriage
very few people have a high quality
relationship when they act like they're
a joint venture instead of a marriage
yeah it sounds like uh you're both on
baby step two
as a family is that right
yes sir now we're talking okay now we
can talk numbers we've set the table
here dave
so let's let's talk about this you've
got 25k in debt she's got this emergency
fund
if you guys brought all of that down to
a thousand dollars for that baby step
one starter emergency fund how much cash
would that leave you
to throw at this debt well actually
me and her both have baby step one done
like we both have two thousand dollars
saved
okay so now we have now so now we have
two thousand dollars
yes okay and we have four thousand
dollars from the wedding
so now we have six thousand dollars am i
right
yes boom okay and then and you have
twenty five thousand dollars worth of
debt
that you're bringing to the table and
she's going to bring how much to the we
she has no debt no doubt well she's got
an emergency fund well i'm sorry
well she's got a mortgage mortgage on
the house are y'all moving into the
house
yes we we moved in together great so we
have a mortgage now good
okay good and so you really got to
practice this that's why i'm being so
dramatic about it
it took me a few years in my marriage
david and it was disastrous
i'll just tell you it's very very
difficult
and i understand that you made the mess
and you're throwing your shoulders back
and saying i'm going to be responsible
and i'll clean up my mess
and i'm not going to ask my wife to
clean up my mess and i appreciate the
manhood of that
and i appreciate the strength that that
represents
and the response personal responsibility
that that represents
but the power of a couple working on
something supersedes that
and so you've got to let her in it's in
sickness and in health
so if you get the flu she gets to make
you soup
that's how it works you know in sickness
and in health for richer for poorer
uh and and the old wedding vows david
said unto thee
all my worldly goods i pledge right
after the
sickness and health thing right and
richer for poor and that was the final
part in the book of common prayer and so
uh and there's something to that this
idea we're going to leave our parents
cleave to each other cling to each other
in desperation and work this stuff
through so how much do you guys make
a year i make uh
55 but i do have child support payments
so after that it's about
50 a year is what i finish out okay and
then about 52 for my wife
okay so you got 100 dollar household
income twenty five thousand dollars in
debt and six thousand dollars in savings
and if so if you work the baby steps the
way we teach and i understand this is
all fresh and it may take you a little
while to digest
but i'm force feeding you with a fire
hose right now okay so what we teach is
one thousand dollars in the emergency
starter emergency fund so i'm taking
five grand throw it at the 20 at the 25
that leaves me 20.
how fast am i going to pay off 20 making
100 probably
six months i'd say they could do it less
if they go hard at this they got a team
now
they could do this thing and and you
know beans and rice rice and beans and
we're gonna bust this
and you're gonna be completely debt-free
and then we're gonna go and start saving
our
fully funded emergency fund then we're
gonna start talking about working our
way all the way through the baby steps
and paying off this house or moving up
in house or whatever it is you're going
to do there
so i think you guys are amazing i think
you're going to do great
uh and i appreciate you coming on in
front of 22 million people let me bust
your chops
but that's you know you're not the first
brother so it's uh um
and you won't be the last but what i
want to do too is i want to give you a
wedding gift
uh since we just spent your wedding
money
i didn't spend it you did when you
borrowed that 25 000. but anyway
uh so i'm going to give you a ramsey
plus for a year which signs you up for
financial peace university for the two
of you to go through together it puts
you in the every dollar premium the
world's best budgeting app
and you'll be able to use all of this
together and george that's a great way
to get started i love it and combine
those accounts if you haven't already
i'm not sure they have
it's time good call touchdown hang on
kelly will pick up and give you our
wedding gift
[Music]
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh how'd
you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you
make the most out of your budget visit
chministries.org
budget don't worry it's worth it
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones here triple eight eight two
five five
two two five when you're struggling with
money it is easy to tell yourself that
you'll deal with it later
or i'll start fresh after the new year
but then later
rolls around and you're still out of
control
hey listen don't wait everyone that does
this stuff
wishes they'd started earlier and you
will too so don't
don't make it a bad thing i mean don't
make it like 10 years ago
no go and do it right now right now
this is the last month you ever have to
worry about money
if you do if that's you we're we're here
to help if you're ready to make the
decision
right now and that's why for this month
only we are knocking thirty dollars off
a twelve month membership to our most
impactful
and life-changing money products see if
you wanna go to financial peace
university
you wanna plug into the premium version
of our budgeting tool every dollar
you do that with a ramsey plus
membership
which for 12 months is 30 off in the
month
of august see you deserve
to be free you just you don't just you
don't deserve to work this hard and be
broke
it's time to change and the stress it's
got to go so start with a free trial at
ramsey plus today by texting trial
to 33 789 text trial 233
789. essene is with us in los angeles
hey a scene what's up
yes hi um we have in this uh we have
saved
200 000 for our children's education
and we will be needing this money uh
seven years from now
so i'm a stay-at-home mom and my husband
works
so we want to invest somewhere where it
is secure
and it can maximize in seven years so
when my children want to go to
undergrad and grad school we can pay for
the tuition and they
remain debt-free wow that's amazing
well done so what's it invested in now
they're not invested they're sitting in
bank in my savings account
so i want to invest and see because i
have been listening to your show and
uh i wanted to know like if i can
maximize like double or a little more
than that
so when my kids go to college they can
just do
their studies and they don't worry about
this debt and all that yeah amen
well done man how many kids do you have
i have three kids one is already in
college and uh
atheism scholarship and the two of them
are younger
so they will take some time like seven
years and nine years to be in grad
school so
that's what i was planning for them that
uh at least
they are covered he's uh he's lucky that
he got all that but
not everyone is lucky wow sharp kids
yeah that's amazing it sounds like the
oldest one's like his mom
so uh yeah
people who make their luck those kind of
people uh
so here's an interesting number if you
had invest if you invest 200 000 at ten
percent
in seven years it will about double so
be worth 400.
if you don't if you don't anything to it
it'll be worth 400. um
if you invested at seven percent it'll
take ten years for it to double
if you yeah and so this is the problem
now
um if i have that money to invest
i'm personally comfortable with and i
recommend putting it in good growth
stock
mutual funds now that does mean you're
going to see some ups and some downs
uh along the way but the averages
are well north of 10 on the stock
market's history
that's the averages now some years it
could be down four percent other years
it could be up 18
and so you know it depends on the ride
on how you get there
but here's the thing if it's average 10
percent if it does
half of what it's averaged we have one
of the worst
seven year periods in history
and it does half for seven years because
it went way up and then went way down
down down down down down and then up
again
and it averages only five percent
it's still five times what you're making
right now
okay so uh if uh like there are certain
mutual funds like you can go vanguard or
federality but
some of them have expense ratio of 0.7
something like that
so what is a good expense ratio we
should be looking at
you know i spend 85 percent of my
analysis on a mutual fund on its average
rates of return
and i only spend about 10 percent of my
analysis on the expense ratios
because the here's the thing if you have
a fund that has a
0.2 0.002 higher
expense ratio but it averages three
percent more you just kicked its butt
right and so everybody gets caught up on
what they
what the expense ratios are and what the
costs are and they're looking at the
wrong numbers
you don't want to ignore that number and
overpay for expenses
but uh you know you can get you can
really miss out on a
really great fun with a really great
rate of return nickel and diming on the
expense ratios so i don't spend a lot of
my personal analysis on my personal
selection that way
but it's obvious you obvious you've done
some research on this know something
about it
what we teach people to do sit down with
a smart investor pro
yeah and i'm curious to your thoughts on
this dave at what point does she go let
me look at an esa or a 529 based on my
income
and see how much we can sock away there
for tax-free growth gonna move as much
of it over there as i can
uh you can't move 200 in one year yeah
there's not not that's not available
that i'm aware of anywhere
on a 529. a lot of 529s are limited to
10k a year
so you can move systematically move some
of it into different kids names
that kind of a thing you know let's say
it did double let's say i went from 200
to 400.
that extra 200 is completely taxable
unless except to the extent you've got
it in a 529 or an esa
or both and then of course it's going to
be uh
completely tax-free on the growth so
that's a really good
really good point you bring up george so
yeah just
go to dave or go to rmcsolutions.com
click on smart vester
and uh sit down with a couple of
different ones and interview them
get let them talk to you about how this
is working what's going on and so forth
and that'll uh
you know once you get the education on
it i think you'll make the exact right
decision very well done
she's amazing yeah greg's with us greg
is in kansas city hi greg how are you
i'm good how are you better than we
deserve brother what's up
well thank you for taking my call um so
i'm pretty new to listen to your show
and i'm looking for a starting point i i
have about
24 000 in debt and i have a big spending
problem
and i hear talk about the baby steps i
don't really know what they are exactly
and i'm trying to figure out a way to go
get control of my french situation
so i want to start a business eventually
very good and
yeah and so i'm trying to sort of sort
through this and get a starting point
how to get this debt knocked out
and move forward cool what's your income
uh about 65 000 a year okay so we got 65
income 24 in debt well in the baby steps
that we teach
uh if you're going all in here's how it
works baby step one
you need a starter one thousand dollar
emergency fund
out the gate okay once you've got that
what's that
i have that you do have that okay and
more and more
i have i have a thousand dollars in
savings that's all i have that's all you
have
okay yeah okay okay so once you've got
that we're gonna move on to baby step
two which is where you're gonna be at
with this twenty four thousand dollars
in debt we are going to use the debt
snowball to attack all of this debt
which means we're listing out each debt
smallest to largest and we're ignoring
the interest rate we do not care about
interest rate this is about behavior
this is about progress this is about
motivation
and as you do that you're going to start
shaving your expenses you're going to
start taking side jobs you're going to
go on beans and rice because we want to
get rid of this thing fast because
you want to start a business you have
dreams and so use that to fuel this
debt snowball journey and then you're
going to take that starter emergency
fund and turn it into a fully funded
emergency fund of three to six months
of expenses and that might take you you
know six months after you've paid off
the debt
and now we're on to investing 15 of our
household income
uh into retirement and then we can go
all right what's it going to take to get
this business
off the ground yeah you get started that
way so baby steps
one is a thousand dollars to recap two
is the debt snowball and that's
scorched earth man nothing is going on
except getting rid of this debt
and the power of what we're what the
reason people are all excited about this
stuff greg is
the reason is because it works and the
reason it works is this
intense focus because you
you and i both know we live in a culture
where no one focuses on anything for
very long
and if you will completely dive in and
focus on
with great intensity this debt you could
be debt-free in less than a year
with your income but that means you
don't have anything else going on you
don't have a life
beans in a scorched earth man beans and
rice rice and beans no eating out no
vacations stop all investing temporarily
any money you have other than that
thousand dollars is not in a retirement
account you throw it at that debt
it's just complete unbridled intensity
and focus and you punch his debt in the
nose and get rid of it
then you don't have those payments
anymore it starts to be very easy to
save
get that emergency fund in place then
you restart your investing in baby step
four
hold on i'm gonna give you a copy of the
total money makeover
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today
one of our favorite things to do is to
take a debt-free scream
here on the air one of our even more
favorite things to do is to have a
debt-free stream on the debt-free stage
in the lobby of ramsey solutions live
and there's only one thing we like more
than that one is one of our own
team members oh yeah i'm just pumped for
this dave this is some of my favorite
stuff right here
is when we get the team members who have
been walking the talk not going ish but
going all in on this stuff
and i'm so excited to have this
wonderful couple with us today so
matt and jessica are with us matt
michaud is our executive director of
data been with us about four years on
our team one of our top leaders in the
whole organization
and uh you did it yeah yeah baby
i love it how much should you pay off uh
just over 215 thousand dollars dave
goodness gracious and how long did that
take 23 months and four days
[Music]
spoken like an executive director of
four days four hours and 32 minutes
215 920 in some odd cents
he knows the somehow too he knows it he
knows it he just didn't want to say it
jessica that's right
that's right no question so what kind of
debt was this
it was our house you paid off your house
baby step
seven in the house whoa i love it
that's so cool i got more team members
with pay how paid for houses it's
unbelievable this is amazing this is a
growing trend
we're just talking in the other hour
george uh he's on track to pay us off by
april
this guy right beside me right here's
getting ready to join you in this the
way to go you guys thank you
you can do this congratulations i'm so
proud of you guys thank you thank you
it's amazing i know when they announced
it the other day in staff meeting
everybody went crazy
and uh just cheering you on it's very
very cool so
one of the things we've done this year
for those of you listening is we've
taken the whole team
that back through financial peace
university and uh we're tracking
uh the whole team as to how much debt
they paid off how much money they've
saved how much mortgage reduction has
happened
and we're tracking every bit of that and
it's called walk the talk in other words
if you're going to be in here
uh talking about telling everybody in
america they ought to do this stuff then
you ought to personally be doing it too
otherwise you're a bit of a hypocrite
and so everybody's game on and matt is
one of the ones paid off their house
absolutely all right you've been here
four years this took
23.4 months right
23 months four days no four days that's
what it was okay
and um so tell us the overall story what
happened what's your all story jessica
well um several years ago i had to get a
a bank statement printed out
and we were budgeting but not i wasn't
paying as close to my
spending day-to-day as i probably should
have been and i went to
get this bank statement printed out and
he said he was going to give me two
months
of a statement and so he's standing
there at the printer and it's going it's
going and it's going
and he hands me this booklet when
we're finally done and i'm looking
through it and it is just
filled with these 5 to 25
charges that i just never planned to
spend
whoa um and i realized it made me it
made me feel sick you killed you killed
trees with that
yeah it was it was ridiculous every time
you know you
you spend the money and it's like well
it's just this little bed and i'm not
like spending it on myself and
you know getting all this makeup or
products and so i felt like i was being
responsible with our money but when i
really looked at
the sheer number of expenses that i had
no idea or had no plan for
spending at the beginning of the month
it was
it was a real eye-opener yeah a big
epiphany right and so that's kind of
when i went to matt i was like you know
we i
want to be more responsible wow with
this
with our budget there's a big difference
between that like 10 000 foot view
budget
and that like 100 foot view budget of
like hey we're in four five and six we
can take
our foot off the gas we didn't actually
have to go through baby step two because
we had really great backgrounds with our
parents brought us up well we didn't
you know we were blessed to go to
college debt-free we were blessed to
have a lot of start out our marriage
debt-free
um but you know that's a blessing and a
curse right because we never learned how
to do that
really intentional focus on our money
and so when she came to me and said hey
what would it look like
if we really did this and we really
pushed hard and we really got down to
the the nitty-gritty of budgeting and
going after this this house and i said
well uh let me put some spreadsheets
together
all right let me do some analysis and
figure it out good
to do a spreadsheet i was like oh let's
do this um and it was going to be
you know a four or five year journey but
it was something we were willing to go
through and um you know god has blessed
us through the process uh
so you got connect did you go through
financial peace or university or did you
end up here first or how did that all
connection
ended up here first um and then kind of
got connected to
the plan and stuff as well i told people
i don't know that i'd get hired today
with how our
hiring practices are in terms of what we
expect from people kind of coming in in
terms of knowing about ramsay but
we were local and i was like hey i know
dave i know who he is i know what he's
about
and i'm in line with kind of the general
concept of what it means to work the
plan i would say we were at best
ish but being here for you know a little
bit of time really quickly taught me
what it looked like to really
walk the talk to really do the stuff
that we talk about and say okay let's
get down into every dollar and let's do
some budgeting and let's
take this stuff serious and it was
amazing what a difference that made
so how do you how do you take this four
or five year journey and go we're gonna
do it in under two instead
that's not an accident uh we've been
blessed
i mean you know i've been working here
for four years and through that time
i've kind of moved from being an analyst
to kind of leading some of the analysts
folks so leading all the analysts folks
and now working in data
over all the data so god has been very
faithful to us as we've
you know tried to work this out the
government's kind of giving us some
money as well in in
covid dave and the government that's all
it takes well it turns out
i told i told the kids that's their
contribution because they're going to be
paying that back someday right
right um but we had 2020 we had kovid we
weren't going out there was nothing to
spend money on so it was really easy to
kind of put your foot on the gas and go
hard at it
wow very cool so what's this house worth
uh it depends i mean if we check now it
might be up another 10 000
who knows but somewhere in the
neighborhood of 520 000.
okay wow wow that's not what we had to
pay for it though thank you lord
amen and how old are you too oh
39 and i'm 41. all right and you have a
paid for half million dollar house yes
sir absolutely how's that feel
unbelievable it's amazing i still don't
believe it dave it's been a couple
months now and it doesn't feel real
even when i walk through the front door
i'm so proud of you guys yeah
so well done matt you're not only a
world-class leader in a
borderline savant but um but the uh
but on top of that you've walked the
talk i mean you you didn't try to you
didn't try to break the system fix the
system you just did it
and i hear you sit at 41 years old with
a paid for house and
and jessica you guys are just incredible
very very well done
and the whole team's half the team's
gathered out here not working
are you paying them to be here they're
just hanging out productivity's gone
down to watch this debt-free scream i'm
just saying
well you know dave you often ask who the
biggest cheerleader was and it's
you can see it in the lobby it's all
these folks yeah it's all these folks
every day
talking about what they're doing and
seeing other team members do their
debt-free screams just being encouraged
over and over and over again it's been
amazing so a lot of positive peer
pressure around this place
yeah yeah so very well done you guys
good job so you brought the kiddos with
you bring them up their names and
ages all right this is patrick he's 12.
this is alexandra she's 10.
and coming down in front down here is
eliza she's
almost five all right very cool very
cool
and they have also been our biggest
cheerleaders okay every time we had
extra money come in
it wasn't a question of where it was
going to go they'd start cheering we
could have put it on towards the house
and now they own their house and now
they've locked this in with this weird
event today
where their own camera and all this but
it's see it's sealed in their soul
absolutely that they this is what my mom
and dad did the day that we changed our
family tree
i'm so proud of you guys it's powerful
it's very cool
all right well just for those of you
listening we don't ask our own team
members their incomes
while all of their peers are staying
don't make a winner so that would be a
little bit awkward so we don't do that
so
but and obviously we don't need to give
him a book because he just got them all
but
we'll get one anyways yeah you get give
any book you want matt i'm just saying
so excellent way to go you guys
excellent job matt and jessica patrick
alexandra and eliza
215 000 paid off in 23 months
and four days it's a half million dollar
house house and everything
we're looking at weird people count it
down let's hear a debt-free scream
ready three two one
[Applause]
incredible and the crowd goes wild
i love it he is a he's an incredible
young leader incredible guy and just
wonderful to see the success that he and
jessica are having so cool that's how
you do it
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today i'm dave ramsey this is
the ramsey show
a show about your life your money and
your life just that simple
fred is with us in san antonio hi fred
how are you
i'm good uh just quick question um
i have a house that during the divorce
uh was given to the ex uh it's 135
thousand dollars but the loan is in my
name
the divorce was three years ago and
my fiance and i we went through the dave
ramsey
uh financial peace class and paid off 38
000 in
10 months good for you and
right now we're trying to get a house
ourselves
but uh we are hesitant on doing that
because of this other loan that's over
over my head you know we don't know
so the divorce decree was your divorce
lawyer sucked
because he left you without the house
and with the loan
correct uh well the the paperwork says
that each one has to pay for their debts
so i was i'm i'm i don't i'm
trying to move forward with trying to
force
i don't know forcing her hand to do that
well that that's you know e the mortgage
should have been addressed in the
divorce decree it wasn't
yeah it wasn't that's weird
yeah okay so basically you don't have
anything from the divorce decree to help
you
um and you you you did a quick claim
deed on the house and so you gave up
your ownership right
correct okay and that was part of the
divorce decree or just part of the
negotiation
uh the product of the divorce decree
what's on paperwork
okay then i suspect the divorce decree
addresses this mortgage but i suspect it
just says you stayed on it
and it didn't ask her to refinance
within a certain period of time correct
correct which is what should have
happened all right so for those of you
listening if you go through a divorce
god help you but if you do
for god's sakes get the mortgage out of
your name as part of the settlement
make the person keeping the house
refinance it into their name
and so that you don't end up where he is
stuck do you remember what the interest
rate is on the mortgage
it's 4.5 okay well the current market is
somewhere around three
do you have any money uh
i uh my fiance and i both together have
about 14 000
saved up okay number one you don't buy a
house with a fiance
you wait or you're married okay okay
because you're gonna get yourself in yet
a different kind of mess
all right but once we're past that the
only way out how's your
how's your relationship with the ex are
y'all on speaking terms
we are on speaking terms we are on
speaking terms
kids involved yes sir okay
so she does not have any reason to
refinance this mortgage
except that she could get a lower
interest rate
right so one way to settle this
might be to offer to pay her refinance
costs
if she will go ahead and refinance that
way she gets a lower interest rate
you get your name off the mortgage okay
okay probably cost you three grand okay
i'm guessing but i mean if you could
talk to her about that and say listen
you're
this is a deal for you you get a cheaper
interest rate and it doesn't cost you a
thing
i'll pay the refinance costs to get my
name off of it
so that i can go buy a house with my new
wife
right and that that sets you free it's a
good deal for her
and it's a the end of a bad deal for you
which is also called a good deal
[Laughter]
so and then you know and then save up
some more money make sure you have your
emergency fund in place you're debt free
you have a good down payment before you
talk about buying your married oh yeah
yeah i don't want him paying off the
ex's house for fun that's not a good
time
let's make sure we look at the fine
print in that decree and and like you
said see if that
she can refinance and take that loan and
it's a good deal for everyone involved
yeah the decree would allow her to
refinance it but it probably doesn't
require her to
um so again uh
it's a a divorce attorney
that's lazy they mail it in
okay and it happens every day tens of
thousands of times a day
and the bottom line is okay we're gonna
split the house mama's going to keep the
house
but we're going to put the house in her
name she gets all the equity and so
you're going to deed the house over to
her
and we forget the idea that he's still
on the mortgage so you have to require
whoever's going to stay in the house in
this case mama to
uh to refinance or we sell the house one
of the two but don't stay
on the mortgage and not keep the asset
as part of your divorce it's a raw deal
man
well you're out of control you don't
control anything you know let's say that
she didn't want to speak to him under
any circumstances there's nothing he can
do
man he's stuck yeah i'd fix this thing
while they're on speaking terms yeah
exactly
vincent is with us in san antonio hi
vincent how are you
hey david george thanks for taking my
call sure what's up
hey just before i start i want to say
thanks for everything you guys do i'm in
the military and i get a lot of
junior guys that work for me that don't
have any um
financial knowledge and i kind of push
them your way as a great way to get
started so thank you for doing
everything you guys do
thank you sir thank you for your service
okay
thank you i appreciate that so my
question for you gentlemen is
i've got a townhouse rental property
and it's in a really hot market and i
got a ton of equity in it
and i don't currently have an exit
strategy
so a cash flow is about 700 a month
and its current equity is about 180 000.
so my question is should i have an exit
strategy
to capitalize on 180 grand worth of
equity within the last four to five
years or should i just keep it
use the cash flow to pay down the
mortgage and just enjoy pay off property
down the road
is this your is this your only property
or do you have uh somewhere you're
living right now with a mortgage
uh that's a great question so the
military currently has me in on-base
housing
and so this is a house i don't ever plan
on coming back to this is
forever going to be a rental and it's
your only mortgage right now
yes sir okay well that's good news
i mean if you're in love with it and you
like being a landlord
there's nothing wrong with keeping it as
long as you're only mortgage but if
you're looking to
maybe get your own place at some point
uh i don't think there's anything wrong
with
cashing that thing out selling it and
investing those profits uh when you're
so that you're ready to move into
something that you want
there's no wrong strategy in your answer
okay a
keep it is not bad b sell it's not bad
okay
there's no end of the world here the the
trick is
to make sure that um that you if you're
going to keep it i
you know real estate i almost never sell
real estate
i just buy it and so i mean i i
occasionally get in a piece of real
estate that something changes and i i
drop out of it sell it
but um but but in terms of investment
real estate
i don't turn it and so it sounds like
this is a solid property it's got good
equity you're making a great cash
flow on it yeah plow the cash flow back
in get it paid off and keep it
if you want to be in the real estate
business with paid for real estate as
your
investment there's nothing wrong that's
a wonderful idea um or you say hey
you know i'm kind of not that enthused
about this whole landlord thing it was
markets hot
it's a great time to jump out i'm going
to jump out take my chips off the table
and go home yeah and at some point he
may want a place for himself and i want
to what if he could pay cash for his own
place
down the line yep and sell this to do it
at that time that would work too
so it doesn't it it's um it sounds like
a solid property everything he used to
describe it all of his adjectives were
positive
yeah i like that so that gives us a hint
that um
he's probably going to hold on to it but
again there's a
you know that some you hit you catch a
market like this once in a blue moon
that's just white hot from a seller's
perspective
and um you know i mentioned in an
earlier hour i sold my home
uh but it's a is a very unusual home and
it and i thought i better take advantage
of a very unusual market
and i'm going to ride this wave and
that's exactly the decision-making i
went through
and now that's different than investment
property because we're changing where we
live
uh not cities but but the actual
location
within this city that we live and so
that's a change but it's part of dave
and sharon's great adventure which
is ongoing you know and so uh we just
it's
it's the whole thing's a freaking ride
for us i'll just tell you so but but
that but that's the thing
the uh to watch the uh
catch the market catch it on a wave
there's nothing wrong with that
and if he's living on base you know he's
in a good spot now if you're looking to
sell it because the market's hot you got
nowhere to live
well you're gonna have to go buy
something else in a hot market so i like
the position he's in
like you said there's no right or wrong
answer if he loves being a landlord
keep it yep that's probably my tendency
in this one but i love being a landlord
so there you go
george campbell my co-host this hour
james childs is our producer kelly
daniels our associate producer and phone
screener i'm dave ramsey your host and
we will be back
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer for
the ramsay show
this episode is over but if you heard
about an event product or service and
didn't have a chance to write it down
don't worry we list everything you've
heard about during this episode in the
podcast show notes section or head to
thermzyshow.com
thanks for listening
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions
broadcasting from the dollar car rental
studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host thank you for
joining us america it is a free call at
triple eight
eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five george camel ramsey
personality is my co-host today we'll be
taking your calls about your life and
your money
you jump in and we'll talk josiah in
tulsa oklahoma starts off
this hour hey josiah what's up
hey dave good to talk to you you too um
so
my question is i am currently a resident
physician in family medicine here in
tulsa
um i have a total debt of a just shy of
about 430 000
uh 415 of that being student loans good
lord
um yeah so but where is it now
um i have one source already of
loaner payment coming in through the
army reserves
that can total amount of 250 000 and
it's split up into increments of 40
000 per year i'm also looking into an
employment option
through the state of oklahoma and
through this employer that has 200 000
in loaner payment over four year period
so 50 000 per year
so my question is is currently in baby
step 2
how would i go about that fitting into
the baby steps if someone is
the majority will be paying off these
loans should i pile up cash in the
meantime while i'm going through those
phases
and set it aside in case anything
happens or let's say you get both of
these deals do they stack
meaning that um you're gonna get the
whole thing paid off
correct yeah so it'd be double dipping
as i call it in a sense so there's
separate entities one would be coming
from the
army reserve the other one will be
coming from this uh this program the
statewide program yeah you won't be able
to finish the army reserve because the
total is
more than you need
see that again 250 and
250 you said right
yes correct yeah and that's 500 you only
have 415. so
the you know the the last two dips from
the army reserve you won't get to
right yeah so it's pretty much a per
year type of thing i know
i'm not opt out or in that yeah i'm just
saying that um you'll
you'll opt out you won't need all the
whole 250 from the army reserve
because it comes over a six year period
of time
so what'll end up happening is is that
you're going to be done
with them paying it in about four years
correct okay all right just making sure
i got my head on straight so
as uh you said family practice right
correct what are you gonna be making
um so at this job it should be right
around
about 300 or so okay
let me tell you the things that i
normally tell people and let's figure
out how to screw them into your weird
situation
all right normally somebody calls me up
and let's say they've got
fifty thousand dollars in student loan
debt and maybe they make a hundred or a
hundred and fifty okay
and they say hey my job is going to pay
this off over three years
well i normally would tell them to be
debt-free a lot sooner than three years
and so what i'll tell them to do in that
case is
i want you to put fifty thousand dollars
in a bank account
to sit there until your job pays off
this loan for you over three years
that way if the job blows up you can
write a check and you're debt free
you see what i'm saying so i'm trying to
figure out how to use that principle
here because i really don't
i really do want you to have these two
entities pay off your 415 over four
years i want that to occur that's an
awesome benefit from both of these
things serving your country and
obviously signing a a competitive
in a competitive landscape signing a
contract with a with an
uh medical outfit okay um
so i want all that to work for you uh
but i also don't want you to sit there
and one of these things blow up on you
for whatever reason
and then you end up three years from now
with still 150 000 worth of debt so
i guess probably what i would tell you
to do is let's try to get a hundred
thousand bucks in savings
before we call you debt free and then
we'll ride this four years out
and just just as a contingency fund in
case something gets sideways
i don't know here's a weird example this
mod this is not going to happen but i'm
just trying to think of bizarre things
that
have called in here over 30 years let's
say you get into this contract with this
employer
and you get in there and there's an
ethics problem
and you got to you have to walk you're
going to lose your dad gum license
because they're just doing stuff right
you got to walk now you got you just
lost 250 000 bucks
and you're you're halfway through this
contract and so you're still sitting
there looking at a hundred thousand
dollars worth of student loan debt
that it's going to take you a lot longer
to get through and um
so i i think uh having that extra 100
laying aside as a contingency way
to step back into this georgia is going
to be a way to kind of call it debt-free
yeah because there's there's some
outside forces here that he's relying on
to get this debt paid off which i don't
like but if there's surefire
and he can stack up this cash and then
he goes oh all right this thing's
actually going to work they're paying
all this debt off for me and now he's
got a pile of cash to continue the baby
steps i like that positioning long as
you stay in the reserve
i think that's one you can depend on but
i think the
rough and tumble world out here in the
real world is stuff happens and these
employment deals blow up yeah and
i don't think it will i think he'll be
okay
but you can't but you have to where
people get themselves in trouble with
money
is they run out the best case scenario
and that's the one they believe and
that's the only way it works is if it
all works
and so you got to run out of scenario
where if it doesn't work
what's going to that also works see
that's the beauty of being debt free
living on a plan living a lesson you
make
that works in good times and that works
in bad times overall
as an overall principle it's the only
set of overall principles
borrowing up to your eyeballs works if
you want to buy a bunch of real estate
nothing down
as long as real estate goes up and all
your tenants pay ha ha ha ha
you know it doesn't work right and so
you got to have a contingency plan in a
worst case scenario
then if your plan works in a in a best
case scenario in a worst case scenario
you got a good plan yeah that's good
battle planning if we're going to use an
army reserve
yeah that's i like that analogy and he's
in a good spot i mean this is a
huge pile of debt so if he can get this
thing wiped out
in a few years he's going to be in a
great spot but man
that's a big hole to dig out of and it's
nice to have that help ouch ouch ouch
that hurts
so um now let's sidebar because you did
this in borrowed future
um we discovered there's really about
three types of student loan
forgiveness that are not private that
are government
and one type well there's one type is
private just kind of the type of thing
he's getting into or if you go into an
underserved area
uh the government will forgive in about
three years
a large chunk of student loan the second
type of student loan forgiveness the
government will forgive your student
loan
in the event of death or permanent
disability the third type of student
loan forgiveness is a lie
public public student loan forgiveness
over 10 years you know it just has not
happened
a you know hundreds of thousands of
applications
uh hundreds of them approved
nightmare 99 dissatisfaction
with that government promise it's pretty
high not occurred
it's not occurred so don't you don't
count on that one while we're on this
subject
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's special savings
[Music]
[Music]
no parent ever wants their child to
experience the panic of
being unprepared for an emergency but
teaching your teens how to be smart with
money can feel like a really big job
hey we got your back with our digital
self-study courses
you can rest assured that your teen will
know the right way to handle money no
matter what curveballs life may throw
them down the road
best part no instructor is needed take
your team through the stuff we teach
if they've got a tablet or a computer
they're ready text
self study to 33 789
and learn more about all the different
courses that we have available for
middle school
and for high school text self study
to 33 7 89
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com find out for yourself why
blinds.com is the number one online
retailer
of custom window coverings you get free
samples free shipping
and with the new promos they run every
month you'll save even more use the
promo code ramsey to get the best
possible deal today's question comes
from mandy in arizona
as a christian i think god expects his
followers to help the needy at whatever
point they are in life
baby step 7 implies that you recommend
giving only after one has paid off all
debts and are comfortable i struggle
with not being able to give while i'm
paying off debt
can you help clarify this for me
i think mandy's got some bad information
i don't ever remember a part where you
said don't give
nope is that part of the baby steps nope
matter of fact we say tithe from day one
for
a christian an evangelical christian and
a tithe is a baseline for your giving
for those of us that are people of faith
uh that's a tenth of your income to your
local church and we start there
now while you're in baby step two
your family's broke and you take care of
your own household
first or you're worse than an unbeliever
is scripture
that's what the bible says so you need
to get your family out of the ditch
so during that two years you don't need
to be giving away tens of thousand
dollars now i mean if you find somebody
hungry and you wanna buy a five dollar
meal i'm there
nobody's ever gonna be mad at you for
that that's not the point i'm not really
mad at you period
but the thing is um you know giving
all the way through tithing all the way
through from the day you start our
program is what we teach
some other giving minor giving in baby
step
two as the holy spirit you know leads
but mainly in baby step two you need to
be getting out of debt now once you've
done that and you're on to baby steps
three four five six
seven your giving should increase that's
living like no one else so that later
you can live and give like no one else
now what we're talking about a baby step
seven is outrageous generosity
i mean over-the-top stuff that blows
your mind money that you where you get
to the point that you give away more in
a year than you used to make
and that's what we're aiming at is this
crazy levels of generosity
and you know you can get there and i
lots of our baby step millionaires have
gotten there
um you know but you're not not giving
right now on baby steps three four
or you're on four five and six trying to
pay off the house house will be paid off
in six months or so
and you're not not giving there right
yeah you keep giving all the way through
and then once you get to seven we just
dial that thing up as much as we want we
can get crazy with it and you unpack
this
masterfully in financial peace
university in the final lesson
outrageous generosity
you walk everyone through this process
and you get them dreaming
and that's what i love as you get them
dreaming about what could it be like
when we have so much money
so much margin left over in our budget
then we can give
outrageously and so you go way beyond
the tithe at that point you can make
crazy things happen you can do wild
offerings at your church you can help
your community
uh you've got tons of stories in there
of ways that people can do this
and that's where things get really fun
yeah so you know
mandy george is right you got bad
information
uh you didn't get didn't have good
clarity so if you've been through
financial peace university you'll see
very quickly we're teaching the tithe
from day one all the way through as a
minimum baseline for an evangelical
christian
off the top before you do anything else
first
fruits and it's not a legalism thing
uh it's uh it's a matter of the
instruction from scripture
and it's a matter of your heart and
setting up you you want to you want to
build the giving muscle in your spirit
and then above that minor giving here or
there
until you're out of debt and have your
emergency fund in place and then when
you break through baby step three
and you start putting 15 of your income
away even though your home is not paid
off
we you're not in trouble anymore but
when you're in baby step two you're in
trouble
yeah you're a bankruptcy looking for a
place to happen and that's most of
america
yep and so uh you've got to be very very
focused to protect your own household
there
but uh but in no time have we told you
to stop giving
ever in 30 years of doing this if i ever
told people to stop giving i haven't
heard it and mandy if you're out there
listening
go check out lesson nine of financial
peace university outrageous generosity
uh if we have your info we'll get kelly
to give you a free
12-month subscription to ramsey plus and
you can go watch that video but that's
gonna really lay it out and
it's very clear we want you to give the
whole way through we just want you to go
wild in baby step seven because you can
there you go put you in a different
place
sylvia is with us in los angeles hi
sylvia welcome to the ramsay show
oh my god hello mr ramsey um
i don't have a question i did stupid on
steroids
we didn't purchase the car in june
please don't get mad 60 000.
and um we gave of that
fifty five hundred was the sales tax and
six thousand dollars
down and we're looking into like um
we tried to send it give it back to the
dealer they wouldn't take it
and we went to carmax and we're looking
into losing
like another um two thousand dollars and
i don't know if
if it's okay and right now my husband
just gone on disability
again because of this back so we're just
on the unsure
i feel stupid losing that money but then
i see stupid all over
around the car when i see the stupid
purchase we did
what do we do what do i do yeah what's
your what's your household income
sweetie
120. that's good news okay
yes yeah um yeah run it back over at
carmax and give them two thousand
dollars and get out of it
yes okay thank you does that feel free
you feel free now yes it does
it does because i keep back and forth
back every time you look at it you can't
catch your breath
yes i i even drive it like
oh my god i was scared and just stupid
too stupid all around
yeah you don't want stupids looking at
you in the driveway every day that's
gonna be a long life
so yeah you need to you need to get rid
of this you need to get rid of this
thing you get rid of it quickly while
while you still can while the while the
getting is good do you guys have another
car
okay yes um he my husband has a truck
it's paid off it's worth 20
but you know we need two cars you know
l.a we
yeah we just need the two cars and i did
have a car
it was reliable you have any money
yes we do how much money do you have
we have um 25 000. okay good take it
take ten thousand go buy you a car
that's reliable that you need just to
get around with
you gotta then you got two paid for cars
and
you make a hundred twenty thousand
dollars a year and then you clean up
whatever other debt you've got you put
your emergency fund back
back in place and um you're going to be
fine so
george the question now we have to ask
you sylvia
what allowed you guys to do this and
what's going to keep you from doing it
again
i think we were always
going back and forth back and forth of
getting a car
and in my mind i i thought like probably
will pay it off in a year you know that
year gap
but then i guess when i we went to the
store or the dealer it was like
i don't i don't even know what to say
dave
it was just stupid and i knew listen i'm
not picking on you but here i'm not
picking on you but here's the trick
i've done a lot of stupid stuff in my
life
my goal is to figure out when i did
stupid stuff
why i did that so that i never do it
again
that's why i'm asking you this not to
shame you i'm just saying
yeah you know you guys need to sit down
and talk about and go are we really
committed to
living our life without payments what's
going to protect us
what's going to be our little personal
behavior insurance policy
to keep us from doing this again yeah
and sylvia i want you to check other
places the market's so hot right now you
can check carvana check out all of the
room all these websites and see if you
can get
a better deal on this but dave's right
and based on our parameters
you can't have your 50 of things with
wheels and motors of
have your household income tied up in
this stuff so you guys got too much car
but you can get out of this thing pretty
quick and never
do it again yeah just because there's
just you know you're just over and over
and over
i wish i hadn't done i wish i'd known so
figure out why you did it never do it
again
so that you never have this kind of a
feeling in your stomach again it's
called regret
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage lauren's with us hey
lauren how are you
oh i'm good dave how are you i'm doing
good where do you live
i mean i live in louisville kentucky i
love louisville it's a great town
welcome to nashville thank you all the
way down here a couple of hours three
hours or so to make your debt free
scream happen how much do you pay off
uh 15 000 excellent
and how long did this take you two and a
half years
very good and your range of income
during that time uh
29 to 35 000 cool what do you do for a
living
um well right now i work at a major
automotive company um on the assembly
line but
i actually quit that this morning to be
honest this morning
i quit this morning yeah because i don't
want to work there anymore but i also
deliver pizza
and i clean a house and basically i read
christy wright's book
a business boutique and i'm wanting to
focus on my own business
wow big step girl yeah throughout that
time though i worked at like
a you know just a cashier job at a
vitamin supplement shop
and i also before i got in the assembly
line i cleaned at the automotive plant
okay so you can do anything yeah you'll
be able to figure it out right
yeah yeah and so you hated that and
you're stuck with it long enough to get
out of debt
basically yeah i'm almost done with your
um financial
uh coaching master class training oh wow
yeah very good yeah how old are you i am
32 years old very good
what kind of debt was the 15 um a little
over
seven thousand each of my car debt and
remaining student loans
and the rest was a credit card all right
very good
so what put what made you decide two and
a half years ago that this was a thing
um
i think it started a little bit before
that whenever i was in a job
situation that i was really scared to
lose my job
and i basically had to like grovel to
keep my job i was in a very desperate
situation and i kind of thought to
myself back then i'm like i never want
this to happen again
but then i bought my house and then
there was unexpected expenses with the
house just like what you talk about
and then at a certain point and i knew
back then i didn't want to be in credit
card debt but i ended up having to put a
home renovation
thing on a credit card i'm like what am
i doing like so i reread the total money
makeover
and i'm like that's it i'm getting out
of it enough is enough
so okay and game on in two and a half
years of miscellaneous 16 different
kinds of jobs
including working the assembly line you
get free yeah wow
what kind of sacrifices did you make
along that journey of two and a half
years
um i i sold my tv
and i gave away my couch i kind of
became a minimalist
oh my goodness yeah i highly recommend
fumio sasaki's
book goodbye things it really helped me
with this
as far as other sacrifices uh sleep
sleep is a thing i'm really excited
about getting a lot of sleep in the
future
that's fantastic so no tv no couch and
no sleep is what it takes for you to
become debt free
wow yeah i didn't get much money for my
tv but it made me a lot more productive
so that's true you don't think about
that part it's not the money that'll do
it it's the productivity
right wow so did you have people
cheering you on was there
anyone around you in this debt-free
journey yeah yeah um
everyone was really supportive of me but
especially my wonderful parents
and my amazing boyfriend over there
yeah they would watch my dog for me
while i would deliver pizza and stuff in
the evening
wow very good good for you thank you
so tell me about this business you want
to start um
well i wanted to be a financial coach to
help people to
um basically follow their dreams and
right now like my dreams are
to become a writer and an artist so i
can focus on my passions because
basically because my expenses are really
low right now
wow that's awesome so you want to go hey
i was screwed
i don't want anyone else to go through
this i'm going to become a financial
coach to help them do this
right and that's part of my dream to be
a writer and do all these other things
yeah and i can help other people follow
their dreams too way to go
very well done proud of you thanks dave
very good
job good job felt good to quit this
morning
it did it's still a little scary but i'm
also
confident that i'm going to make it
happen yeah you won't have any trouble
landing another position if you need
something i mean you can do anything
because you've done anything and
everything and so you can go do
something else if you have to she's not
scared of
a stop gap whatever it takes so i can't
tell if the smile is from quitting her
job or
being on the debt-free stage
maybe both maybe both yeah well that's
the beauty of having uh your finances in
order you can um
tell them to take this job and yeah
there you go so
very good good job well done all right
lauren we've got a copy of the legacy
journey for you that's the next chapter
in your story for sure
and uh of course we've got a copy of the
total money makeover as well for you to
give away and pay it forward to someone
else
get them started on this journey with
you and uh congratulations
thank you you're a hero well done and uh
you put yourself in a great position
how's it feel to be here
it feels really really amazing like
honestly
i i swear i submitted it i thought oh
well they're never going to contact me
because i just not like 150 000
of debt but i'm hoping that i can
inspire people who don't make
as much money that they can get out of
debt too you did
29 000 income 15 000 paid off yeah well
done
thank you good job very good job it's
pretty amazing what you do what you've
done
so uh we're very very proud of you all
right lauren from louisville kentucky 15
000 paid off in two and a half years
making 29 to 35
working everything in sight to make it
happen count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream three
two one i'm debt-free
i love it
[Music]
she's my age you know what that tells me
there's some millennials out there who
suck and there's some who are awesome
that's right she's one of the awesome
ones i say that all the time man
awesome and sucks and the awesome are
awesome that's encouraging very cool i
mean don't read the headlines
yeah i don't believe the headlines
there's lots of great
great people in this generation it's
pretty incredible they're on this debt
free stage every week for sure
open phones this hour as we talk about
your life and your money thank you for
joining us america george campbell is my
co-host today
lisa is with us in savannah georgia hi
lisa how are you
i'm hanging in there dave how are you
doing better than i deserve how can we
help
well um this is kind of a strange call i
was really
on track with y'all's program and hope
to have been there to do a debt-free
screen
anywhere from three to five years made a
lot of progress
in the meantime my partner decided that
they didn't want to be married anymore
and
i've got a lot of medical issues with a
couple of points away from
being listed for a liver transplant and
now i'm dealing with
uh you know trying to not lose all my
equity in my home and i'm being
called a squatter by his attorney i mean
it's just a
i don't know what to do um
you're being called a squatter by his
attorney
is there a negotiated settlement on the
divorce yet
no sir and you're not a squatter he's a
butthole
right i we had he had an agreement for
four years to
pay support and let me stay on health
insurance
so hopefully i could have had my liver
transplant by then a year into it just
decided he didn't want to
you know uh honor that
i don't care what he wants to honor you
have an agreement
yeah but unfortunately they can just
change their mind
so now what i'm doing is trying to fight
i've always been a homeowner i've prided
myself
in that well the negotiation is not over
but he doesn't get to unilaterally
decide
that you're a squatter and that you have
to leave you have an argument here that
you own half of this property
and it's a divorce uh disagree divorces
you know the problem is that a friend of
mine does divorce recovery work he says
divorce turns a marriage into a business
transaction
and so it's no longer about i don't
really care what you
think about me i don't really care what
your attorney thinks about anything
uh it's not it's not on my list of
people that i have to keep happy anymore
you're no longer on that list you've
abandoned me
and so now all i care about is what the
transaction looks like
and you and your attorney just negotiate
the transaction it may involve selling
the house if you want to
uh but he doesn't get to tell you what
to do
so if it's best for you to sell the
house and get the equity out and split
it with him and go on your merry way
that's fine if it's best for you to
fight and make him honor what they
originally agreed to
which i kind of think sounds like it is
then fight it kiddo
you know these guys these guys don't get
to be bullies and just get to decide
punch them back she's a fighter i can
tell absolutely
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day romans 15 13
may the god of all hope fill you with
all joy and peace
as you trust in him so that you may
overflow with hope
by the power of the holy spirit
agmandino said failure will never
overtake
me if my determination to succeed
is strong enough francis is with us
francis is in pittsburgh hi francis how
are you
thank you for answering my call i really
appreciate it sure what's up
um well i'm a 22 year old
sophomore in college right now and i've
been working minimum wage jobs since
18 and i've i've managed to save up a
total of
about 8k but i hate my minimum wage job
and i've
never been prior or anything like that
i've worked consistently hard like 50 to
about 60 hours a week
and i don't know i just want to get out
of
minimum wage status and do something i
like
i know where i want to go i know what
type of job i want to do i want to do
i want to do sales i don't really
care what i do in sales as long as i'm
not selling insurance
i love i love the art of selling but
however there's a problem
i don't have a car and i came from a
foreign country
and i've been living in the states for
about two years
but i don't know how to get a job
without with
starting out with not making enough
money to manage to be able to get a car
and paying for the
maintenance fees for it so i take it
you're not in school
uh this is an off month right now
are you no no i'm sorry are you are you
in college
yeah okay i live i live right next to
the university
what are you studying marketing
okay all right uh francis what's your
what's the country you came from
well i lived as a kid i lived in japan
both my parents are american so at least
that's good
but um it's totally different
so it has to get adjusted to here and i
haven't quite fully adjusted yet
in what way how long have you been here
i've been in the states for about a year
so what is the adjustment that needs to
happen i'm not familiar with the
cultural difference between japan and
the us that would require an adjustment
i don't understand
well um it's the fact that in japan
everything is so compact
they have public transportation and the
fact that i
don't really have a way of getting
around is killing me but i don't make
enough money uh to manage to get a car
or you have eight thousand dollars
go buy a three thousand dollars i'm
worried but i'm worried it would eat up
all my savings
go buy a three thousand dollars i'm
already in bed go buy a three thousand
dollar car
with cash
okay and then for god's sakes never take
another minimum wage job they suck
yeah i know they suck no it's horrible i
mean go go mow grass and walk
dogs you can make twenty dollars an hour
doing that clean toilet you can make
twenty five dollars an hour doing that
yeah this is the world of entrepreneurs
my son
enter it i okay i'll i'll
do whatever it takes yeah and in the
meantime
in the meantime uh other than paying for
the car
uh what should i do with the other
portion of the save the money because i
don't want to lose whatever i have
you got debt you said how much debt do
you have
uh currently i have about 25k debt
in college okay student loans i'm not
worried about that today you're in
college it's in deferral
and what i want you to do right now is
to get your head straight on this career
thing
to where you go i have a value in the
marketplace and i'm going to scratch and
claw i'm going to find something to do
so uh francis i had a young guy that
worked here years ago
and he came uh from czechoslovakia
and uh he
left here as because he was just so
entrepreneurial he couldn't work for
anybody
he was just had to be doing something
for himself he just he was so proud to
be in america
so proud to have the opportunity to do
anything he wanted to do and he sent me
an email two weeks later and he said
i just bought a garage of
i went to a garage sale and i found a
guy that was a nike salesman
and he had all of last year's samples
and he goes i just bought the whole
garage full
for a hundred dollars i put them on ebay
and in four hours i sold them for ten
thousand dollars i love america
so this is this is his mindset and so i
want you to go about
four notches his direction from this
stinky minimum wage side of the spectrum
that you're stuck on
and i want you to go over there where
pavlov lives and because pavlov man that
kid
god man i'm like hello and he literally
wrote at the bottom
what a country you know i mean it's just
like yeah you dad come right
there's nowhere else in the world that
you can leave a job
and in 48 hours you go buy out a nike
garage for
salesman's garage sale for 100 bucks to
sell it for 10 000 bucks on ebay that
afternoon
i mean you know it's just but there's
stuff like that all over the place yeah
you know as long as there's garages
we're not going to be unemployed you
know yeah
so you know my point is francis you
don't ever need to take another minimum
wage job again you need to get your head
around that
that's the important thing and then
that'll help you to finish your
education without any more debt
and then when you graduate with your
marketing degree you're gonna have a
whole new set of
uh of eyes on how you look at things
yeah he's gonna have a whole new skill
set and
get a great job in sales and i want more
hunger i'm seeing a lot of excuses but
francis is also saying
i'll do whatever it takes i want to feel
that hunger and i think like you're
saying there's a lot of opportunity out
there to go make some money if that's
the issue right now and once you're out
of college
you'll get a bigger shovel we'll get the
student loan debt cleaned up but i think
it's a paradigm shift right now that
francis needs to make
yeah you know it's there's a lot of
stuff you can do to make money
in this world and uh minimum wage is
just
it's uh you know i i don't argue with
people about the minimum wage because i
don't think anybody ought to take that
job
i think you ought to go do something
else you know it's like mcdonald's
doesn't pay enough
great don't work at mcdonald's doofus go
do something else
you know walmart doesn't pay enough
great don't work at walmart you know
it's a free country go work somewhere
where you can make more money
but you don't get to tell those people
what to do you just go do your thing
but everybody's so dadgum worried about
managing everybody else's business in
this country today
you know mind your own dad gum business
and go do your thing man
so yeah you're not gonna you're not
gonna get rich
and you're not gonna have anything but
financial trouble working minimum wage
jobs
and so you got to decide something
different and i mean
man you can cut grass and make 25 an
hour yep
so george i learned this stuff i guess i
grew up with entrepreneurs so
i was 12 years old scared him oh lost 12
years old i had 27 yards to cut most of
them were three dollars to four dollars
a yard
and i'm such a dead gum math nerd that
minimum wage in those days was a buck 65
an hour wow
okay so i figure if i can cut the grass
in
under an hour for three bucks i made
double minimum wage
and so i would start a stop watch and
see if i could beat
double what my buddies were making
flopping whoppers
and so this is how my brain worked my
whole life and so
i want to transfer one or two of those
brain cells from me to you francis right
now
okay i want you to start thinking that
way and go how can i make double triple
quadruple
or matter of fact where i don't even
think about hourly ever again i just
think about profit
oh yeah and there's so many sales jobs
out there entry level cold calling stuff
and if he's hungry
he's going to make way more than minimum
wage doing that hustling grind baby
hustle and grind
and if you know how to sell you're right
sell something other than insurance get
out there and sell something i don't
care what it is
i mean as long as you're not ashamed of
it but god you can wake
tables at a nice restaurant and maybe a
bazillion times more
than minimum wage it's hard work i
wasn't suggesting none of this is easy
but good god being broke is hard too
yeah so pushing that through so your dad
first generation right
yeah yeah my parents immigrated here to
this country and they went through a
similar thing where they
they had to go to college and kind of
earn earn their stripes a little bit and
get into these jobs that maybe
didn't pay well and move their way up
over time
but your dad and your mom i mean i've
met them they they hustle and grind
oh yeah i mean they're middle eastern
they're not scared of work and they like
a good hustle and they're real frugal so
they can make money work
yeah and you know that's the beauty of
the american dream right there and
you know and then here's you know george
campbell with a k
sitting here right you know no one
thought it would happen yeah there we go
but we're here yeah very very cool
that's the american dream dave
i think it i think it's a beautiful
thing it's absolutely
incredible and i promise and i promise
to pay you more than minimum wage
thank you dave and it starts today james
and kelly you have it on good authority
it's on tape
it's right here it's on youtube it's on
it's in the cloud
you've got you got record of this george
proud of you man it's on youtube forever
that puts us hour the ramsey show in the
books we'll be back with you before you
know it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk
daily with the friends of peace christ
jesus
[Music]
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show
did you know over 18 million people
listen to the ramsey show every week and
a lot of those people listen on one of
our 600 plus radio stations across the
country
to find a station near you head to
[Music]
thermsyshow.com
you